[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
June 16th I'm J.R Wellen for the Wall
Street Journal
some good news for renters monthly
payments are declining after several
years of steep increases Wall Street
Journal reporter Will Parker joins us so
will how much have rents risen on
average over the past several years
since the pandemic rent went up
something like more than 25 percent
according to most metrics and it did
that really quickly you know within
about 18 months certainly in less than
two years and there's really no
comparison for that in recent history it
was a rate of increase that certainly
most renters had never experienced in
their lifetimes renters were really
taken by surprise and their income had
fallen off because of the pandemic on a
lot of occasions yeah especially early
on in 2020 I had a lot of job in
security a lot of layoffs and it wasn't
long after that that you started to see
things changing the housing market and
prices go upwards before many people had
really recovered so what kinds of
declines are we seeing so what we're
seeing right now broadly is not so much
a decline in the nominal rent that
you're charged every month but just this
out of control growth of rents upwards
is coming back down to earth so the pace
of the rent increases is much much
slower it's pretty close to flat and a
few parts of the country the rents that
landlords are charging is actually down
somewhat it is negative and those places
include cities in the southwest like
Phoenix or Las Vegas which saw some of
the most stratospheric rent increases
earlier in the Pandemic those places
prices are starting to come down but
broadly what you're having nationally is
a moderation and rent is finally not
catapulting upwards like it was what
economic factors are causing this shift
you know it's a few things starting last
year you started to see demand for
apartments calm down a bit fewer leases
happening vacancies rising and part of
that was simply the rent prices were too
high to be sustained that there were too
many renters that had to make critical
decisions about their housing because of
how high prices were so things like
adding roommates moving back in with
friends and family or simply just not
deciding to move up in life you know
house moving from a smaller apartment to
a larger apartment all of that started
to back off and that meant prices could
not continue to grow at the same level
they had been other things that were
happening is that the migration we were
seeing people moving across the country
to new cities and driving up demand
people moving into sun built cities from
the Northeast that kind of activity is
also slowing somewhat and that's also
keeping the demand down in some of these
markets that had just grown so quickly
are we talking rents across the housing
rental Spectrum where we're seeing a
shift in the rents yeah we're seeing a
shift in apartment rentals and in
single-family home rentals but it looks
like you know from most of the data
sources that we have that the Slowdown
and apartments is greater than it is for
single-family home rentals and part of
that might be that the demand for
single-family home rentals because of
how difficult it is to buy a house is
remaining pretty strong because if you
can't buy if interest rates are just
much too high for you to stomach right
now the closest option for you is to
rent a similar house and what does this
mean for renters who've been dealing
with double-digit percentage increases
for the past several years well
critically one thing it means is that
when you go to get a renewal from your
landlord if you're going to stay the
rent that they're going to ask you to
pay is going to need to come down as the
prices for apartments that are available
out in the market are no longer
skyrocketing anymore so what we're
seeing is it's not happening super
quickly but landlords are going to have
to adjust their expectations for what
their current tenants can pay based on
what the rest of the market is doing so
we're going to see more cases where
tenants see an opportunity to move to a
better apartment with a better rent if
their landlords are not adjusting their
expectations for what rents are now as
quickly as they should be perhaps
speaking of landlords we saw them get
caught in the middle here especially
when rent payments were frozen during
the pandemic what does this shift mean
for them non-payment of rent has not
been a huge Factor in most of the
country even back earlier in the
pandemic it went down for a while but
rebounded quite quickly things like
rental assistance from the federal
government helped make up a lot of that
Gap so you know things have continued to
be pretty good for property owners and
even if rents are flattening out now of
something like 30 percent increase that
they enjoyed over the last couple of
years they're still benefiting from that
the ones that have some problems or they
could have some problems are investors
who bought buildings recently with a
speculative business plan that depended
on a rate of rent increase that no
longer exists so people who bought
buildings maybe a year or two years ago
thinking that rents will keep going up
double digits and basing their whole
business around that those people
narrowly may be experiencing some
trouble because of what's Happening Now
did they misjudge the market potentially
some investors certainly did not
anticipate a year in which rent did not
go up at all and that may be a
complicating Factor if that happens and
that's that looks like what's going on
now is a full year of of either no
increase in asking rent or even negative
which is where we may be heading in
months that are upcoming what factors
could cause rents to turn around and
rise again if the economy stays pretty
stable we don't have a big increase in
unemployment if businesses decide they
want to start growing again that may
mean that more renters and young people
decide to start households move out and
get their first apartments and move up
to bigger or better apartments and that
sort of demand will prop up rents and
will cause rents to perhaps start Rising
again but I don't think anyone foresees
a scenario in which rents go back to the
double-digit streak that we saw on the
pandemic anytime soon that's Wall Street
Journal reporter Will Parker and that's
it for your money briefing this week
before we go a quick programming note
we'll be off on Monday in honor of
Juneteenth but we'll be back on Tuesday
with a new episode our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris zinsley I'm
your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]